[Musik]
1 1 nach den wichtigen aufgaben hat
überlegt alles noch relativ normal
blog.info ich euch gesagt sein land
einheitlich was sollte ich machen werde
wie üblich ist eigentlich und kollegen
lernen war schon für dringlich die
heutigen plan so aufgeht wie ich mich
vor ort ein paar hat entweder ich möchte
der ausbeute heutigen blogger hofft so
auf dass ich euch ein bisschen frei
gemacht wird mein plakatiert inzwischen
etablierten reagiert einfach mal wieder
auch in familien mir auch dritte 1
gewinnen
[Musik]
grund damit herzlich willkommen jetzt
hier heute zu einer neuen ausgabe luca
reagiert
das beste format auf youtube okay leute
muss es wirklich berger hannah wir haben
die erste anwendung etwas von einer
pension talent hat also ich weiß nicht
ob es eher hobby losigkeit ist oder
wirklich talent das sie aus allen als
spielen irgendwie ein haus gebastelt hat
war barbara
diese fahrbare bahre bedeuten soll oder
ob der rhabarber halten soll
da aber das irgendwie dazu fiel am ende
war barbara hey es ist cool dass sie mir
geschickt hat es hat eine erste auto
gedacht dass mir so etwas sagt oder
irgendwie so aber da barbara auf jeden
fall auch etwas was ihr keine ahnung was
wir damit meinen sohn luca erhaltet ihr
den clip ok super cool wir halten fest
lukas krieger hatten allerdings die wir
schauen uns mal an was sein könnte wie
die hhl ist aggression
[Musik]
chf ab
niemand
[Musik]
es wird jemand
ich bekäme eben lukas lust zu der szene
auf jeden fall auch noch sagen dass ich
sehr gut fand dass wirklich alle
synchron und keiner danach gezogen hat
danke auf jeden fall an sich hat
hersteller
haben sie gesagt sie würden sich sehr
schön finden
wieso würdet ihr euch schön wenn ich mal
wieder neues video mit
[Musik]
becker
danke an euch auch für diese anwendung
diesmal wirklich alle synchro der
komische hybrid man nicht dabei an der
stadt auf jeden fall unser dank an euch
ihr seid auf jeden fall waren lud ruhm
mitglieder apropos luxury meine damen
und fünf andere produkte wisst ja bereit
viele fragen mich ja was sind denn jetzt
eigentlich die allgemeinen produkte die
dort neu kommen ich mache das ja
eigentlich nie dass ich das jetzt im
monat vorher ankündigen oder so morgen
kommt ein kollege von mir der braucht
ein ukrainischer punkt de arbeitet kommt
bei mir vorbei und zeigt mir die mutter
von den neuen sachen sind endlich mal
angekommen weil wir haben wieder so ein
bisschen von der qualität zum beispiel
wir haben eine daumendicke t shirt dicke
falls nicht wird was dem t shirt dicke
es guckt euch einfach beispielsweise
dieses t shirt anders als zum beispiel
sehr sehr dick das merkt man auch schon
an der qualität deswegen gern die
bisherigen t shirt shop ich weiß nicht
die hatten aber die neuen indes auf 320
gramm zu für t shirts echt eine menge
deswegen leute wartet einfach ein
bisschen ab folgt oder instagram sich
wer denkt da so ein paar bilder
raushauen hintereinander kommen
sie machen weiter mit der nächsten
einwendung ich denke mir immer okay
wollte etwas zu sagen oder dass es
einfach so im raum stehen
ich glaube ich dass es einfach mal so im
raum stehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch heute ist wirklich keine luca
reagiert episode sondern einfach nur so
hey geschickten luca irgendwelche
komischen videos von babys neuen formen
zu ich muss an der stelle wirklich sagen
dass sie gesungen
das ist vor allem auch mit der gitarre
oder mit einer ukulele gespielt aber
leute ihr wisst alle ich habe das auch
schon mal gesungen bei mir kriegen zum
welten besser
[Musik]
eigentlich könnte ich auch ein cover von
haut ist von bibi machen
ab heute präsentieren eine coverversion
von green house ist
der kollege von mobi karte das ebenfalls
von hochgeladen luca krieger hatten wir
heute der heute wieder wurde mit dabei
und wir hatten sogar schon den wunsch
der das ganze auch schon gesungen hat
und jetzt meine damen und herren wer
hätte damit rechnen können und machen
einfach wirklich auf meinen körper an
der stelle muss ich sagen dass hier
wirklich noch mal kurz die luft gemüte
führen
ja
jetzt können wir auf jeden fall auch die
lyrics
[Musik]
einfach dein maul lukas wir jemanden der
sich in island macht leute wie gesagt
[Musik]
das medley von lukas hundekot macht ihre
erkenntnis nicht
eingesendet alter
[Musik]
er hat einfach mal hintergrundmusik
nachgespielt alter mega gut geworden
bevor der block jetzt normal weitergeht
also ich habe schon gedacht wird heute
einfach nicht viel passieren und kollege
kommt rum und wir lernen noch wie vor
der blog jetzt weitergeht noch eine ganz
kurze sache und war mehr wird von vielen
leuten getragen überbietet sich leute
ich mache mir nicht immer wie möglich
reagiert die als person sondern
lediglich ihren content die ihre musik
und damit wenig einfach schreiben
dahinter fanden dass die mega nett ist
aber so konnten und musik ist einfach
nicht so ganz mein ding und das darf
natürlich öffentlich auch sagen und noch
eben zu einer anderen sache hier
bezüglich der format rücker reagierte
wurde der twitter wieder unglaublich
viele videospiele sendung habe ich viele
leute die auch meinte hey luca wir da
schon drei söhne hat mit reingenommen
hier das technikum genug oder irgendwie
so nein leute ich nehme ja auch voll auf
leute mit rein in die talente haben
kröpfl heute die sängerin oder der typ
hier der am ende die liga von meiner
kinder von meiner hintergrundmusik auf
dem klavier nach gespielt hat allerdings
sind viele videos die mir eingesendet
werden dann irgendwie drei minuten lang
oder so die nehme ich natürlich mit
rainer husty zu lang und das problem ist
auch dass bei vielen videos auch einfach
musik genommen wird die copyright
geschützt ist das darf ich einfach nicht
mit rein ich will hier niemanden
ausschließen oder so ich versuche alles
mit einem packen aber dieses format geht
nicht eine stunde lang am tag und ich
habe als auch nicht rechtlich sicher
musik aber jetzt geht der blick erstmal
weiter
der kollege kommt jetzt gerade das
eingesandte werden die wird dann
lernfortschritt bekennerschreiben als
bester schweizer ist auf jeden fall
dürfte mittlerweile am start er gerade
400.000 auf youtube erreicht das was
möchte dazu sagen dass jetzt gerade 15 6
stunden vergangen wir haben wirklich in
den letzten weg 78 stunden nur gelernt
irgendwelche uniqlo dieses video auf der
vereinigung bräuchten wir haben
allgemein auch mal in die kommentare die
ihre kraft findet als wie findet ihr das
wenn ich das kann die schneide die
rechnung mache mich interessiert eure
meinung einiger werke nicht um irgendwie
mitbekommen was mir überhaupt nicht
bringt mich dafür wirklich interessieren
oder er abbrechen
sonst würde ich natürlich immer am ende
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat will ich
mich berger den leicht von euch freund
schneit bedacht wie gesagt einfach in
die kommentare hat mich diese gut
gefallen habe ich das weitermachen
sollen morgen dem anderen video nieder
[Musik]